live your life the way you want to go
out
because ultimately that's what's that's
what we're all doing we just don't know
it but we're living our lives the way we
want to go out
what kind of heart does it take to
pursue this business
or is heart not part of the picture
um
heart
meaning
passion
it has to be
something that um
it's it has its own rechargeable battery
i don't think that i think you have to
go hard i think you have to go hard all
the time and you have to
uh
i know for me i i i was having this
conversation while i was saying before i
hear a lot of people say oh i die to
make a movie i die to make a movie and i
say i would never die to make a movie
it's not there's tons of stories you can
tell and all that stuff but i've got to
finish one because
with all the planning and everything
that goes into making a movie
it's having that passion that's gonna
help you finish a movie
because for all the movies that are out
there that you can think of
think about it this way if you saw a
hundred movies
there were probably
50 000
that got they started making but never
finished
and of that 50 000
there were probably a hundred and fifty
thousand scripts that were in
development and about to start
production
so if you look at that number and it
filters all the way down to just 100
films it's not about
getting the opportunity to make a film
it's about finishing a film and that
takes a passion where you where you have
to go into it with the understanding
that no matter how excited someone is
about your project be it the actor the
the cinematographer
the editors anybody who's working on
that film that's not you
those people for as excited as they are
they do not care as much as you do
they never will
so when things start breaking down
and it's got to be spit bubble gum and
duct tape to keep it together and to
keep it moving it's going to be you
it's going to be you and the second you
get tired and you can't finish it that's
when it stops
that's when it stops
because you you're the you're the person
you're the battery you have to keep
recharging that battery that passion you
have to keep it going and it has it has
to push you all the way through
every adversity and every um
every obstacle
to get to completion
it has to push you
and it can't die ever because that's
when the project will just cease to
exist and once it once it stops it's
very rare that projects get picked back
up and they finish them it's very rare
so i would i would say in terms of heart
i'd relate it to passion
and say that yeah it has to be a
rechargeable battery that just doesn't
die it can't die now if you're saying
what kind of heart in terms of
caring and compassion and that sort of
thing
i don't know how far that gets you
i don't know i think if you if you get
into films that are very much about um
uh
society and how to push society forward
and make people think about the world
they live in and that sort of thing if
that's the direction you're going in i
think that having a heart is
for compassion and and love and and all
that great stuff i i think that it's
i think that it's it's paramount in that
because
there it takes a great amount of will
that willingness to understand people
and open yourself up to to learn about
others and to learn about their cultures
and whatever it is that you're going to
be talking about in that film it does
take a great amount of of heart and
compassion to do that to be willing to
to
completely immerse yourself in someone
else's world
but those are two very different hearts
i think
two very different hearts sure and there
can be a downside to the other heart in
that things can affect you too much i
mean there's been documentarians that
have ended their lives because they saw
things they didn't want to see yeah
about different countries or wherever
and the atrocities that were going on so
that can it can also take you down
because there are things you can't unsee
and uh and once you're made aware of
them your deep feeling for those things
it can affect you in some profound ways
in ways that you you don't expect
you know i i i
i will never forget um
there was a time back in what was it
maybe
maybe oh nine
was it on nine maybe on nine oh nine i
was doing marketing for a skilled
nursing facility
and it required that i have a nursing
background but i said you know there's
nothing i can learn so of course i had
to you know really hit the books and
learn a lot of nursing terms and things
of that nature
but i digress
the thing was is there was a patient of
the skill nursing facility that ended up
in the hospital and i had to go visit
them
and just kind of see how everything was
going make sure social workers were on
it and everything and they told me the
guy wasn't going to be
released because now he's definitely
needed to stay because he has a stage
for decubitus ulcer and i was like stage
four to cupid of souls i've heard of
those those are bad and they're like
yeah they're bad here's a picture of it
and that picture i cannot see
i cannot see it's uh it's
when a bed sore has basically eaten its
way to the bone almost
wow and when i saw that i was like
ah why would you why would you not like
give me a second before you did that
that's permanently
in my mind and now i associate it with
this patient that i've grown to care for
so now i'm i'm more like
emotionally invested in this person it
makes it hard to do my job now because
you're the only thing you're thinking
about is there to keep this ulcer but
you forget the other reasons why they
were there in the first place the only
thing you want to do is make sure that
gets healed because that is the most
painful thing that someone can go
through it's an incredibly painful thing
and if you if you've ever seen it acute
of stage 40 cubitius ulcer i apologize
to you in advance that you had to see it
because it's it's a very nasty wound
very nasty wound
you know
well maybe this is too personal we can
cut this out so i'll ask it and if you
don't want to did you move on from the
job i did i did i eventually i
eventually had to move on from from
working in a skilled nursing facility it
was
it was a place where you you get to know
everyone by name you know and you get to
to learn their dietary needs and
everything you know so much about you
know more about them than their families
do
and you spend more time with them than
their families do
and you begin to care about them deeply
and
to to always
after it happens the first few times
when someone that you know and you speak
to every day passes away it's like it's
a huge shock
and
it's something about that realization
when there is no longer a shock
and that was the moment i realized i've
been here too long
when i changed from
talking about people that i know and
that i care about when i stop it
saying that they've passed away that
they've died i stopped saying that and i
started using the medical terminology
which was they expired
that's when i knew
i
i think i need to step away from this
it had become death had become way too
clinical for me
wow yeah did you take time for yourself
after that or you had to go into another
job right away
i no i took a little time away i took a
little time away as a matter of fact i i
think that that was the impetus to make
me say i i i really just want to focus
on the arts i i really
i started having conversations with
people and
i don't know how it sounds now i really
don't know because back then it was so
clinical
it still feels clinical when i say it
but i started telling people
i've seen the end
live your life the way you want to go
out
because ultimately that's what's that's
what we're all doing we just don't know
it but we're living our lives the way we
want to go out
so
either your mind's going to go first or
your body
but live your life the way you want to
go out
and
as i said that more
i realize you know what i
i will
i will start feeling that regret
that i'm not supposed to feel
if i don't
now start going 100
after my plan a
that's when you'll start having that
regret when you see an opportunity that
you let pass by
um and
doing that actually led me into uh the
film x-men at cutters creek
they really did it was because i left
that
and i just sat down and really just got
back to writing and said i just want to
pursue this and i want to shoot a film
by this date i want to forget everything
i've been doing before this and i want
to shoot this film
and so that's what i did i just devoted
all my energy to that
and funny enough
a doctor that i met actually ended up
financing that film
and so it just worked out you know in
that way but uh the impetus for that
the the thing that pushed me to get away
from that and into this was that
realization and sorry this was the first
axeman the first example okay so 2012
2013 yeah we shot it in 2012 i believe
yeah
2012 is when we actually shot it but
before that it was it was me
writing and going to everyone and trying
to figure out who was going to finance
this thing and
you know it eventually worked out it was
the first time i'd done that before that
prior to that everything i'd done was
self-financed
and then
i just realized this one's too big of a
film for me to finance on my own
and so i did go around looking for
um you know a financier or producing
partner somebody to help me get the
movie
made
and so you were we were coming out of a
recession
and so with money was tight for a lot of
these investors or yeah money was very
tight and two
there's a certain amount of
vanity and ego
that comes along with i guess sometimes
financiers
so that made it
that made it a little tough it made it a
little tough uh it was very funny i
learned a very
an interesting lesson i have a buddy of
mine and and uh i don't mind mentioning
his name he won't mind either his name
is eddie l watkins
and he's a very big stunt coordinator in
the business and he's be producing now
as well
and
he was in these meetings with me as we
were going around and everything and one
of the one of the investors
said you know what i i would just prefer
if we do
these scenes the way i've written and he
hands me pages that he's now written
to rewrite my script right
and so he hands me these pages
and he hands one to eddie
and we're in this meeting and eddie
doesn't even read it he just looks at me
and i'm reading him looking at eddie
and i'm like i don't understand why you
would do this this is not you know i'm
trying to give him my notes on what he
written and the guy is puffing up his
chest and you know he's doing those
things and again eddie's just watching
and uh the guy won't accept any notes
he says to us look
this is how the film needs to be written
if you want my money because he who
makes the gold
he who has the gold makes the rules guy
actually said that wow and eddie without
missing a beat says that's only if we
want your gold
and i look at him
are we walking
and he says yeah we're walking that's it
meeting over
and we literally walked out of the door
and that was it i thought
we finally had a guy you know and he was
you don't want to work with a guy like
that because if you don't if you can't
get along with him now and if he has no
flexibility now he'll have none during
production and he'll think that every
idea
is supposed to end up on the screen and
that's not someone you want to work with
especially if their ideas
don't work for the project
and it was very funny because walking
away from that we eventually walked into
the investor that we did use yeah it was
a very scary time because i walked away
from that job and i spent a lot of time
trying to get the ball rolling but
what i did was i took plan b
and i tossed it
and everything that came
below that no plan c d no escape routes
no nothing i want to make this movie
and i want to make it next
and that's exactly what happened because
i didn't give myself an alternative i
didn't give myself
you know
a way out of it a way for it not to
occur
when you met with the he who has the
gold makes the rules person
how many investors in was that how many
meetings in was that a first meeting no
that was probably our second
okay that was probably our second or
third
yeah probably our second or third
but you you and and your your friend the
stunt coordinator both just had like a
gut reaction like if it's bad now
this is the honeymoon phase it's not
going to be it's not going to improve
well
here's
here's the back story to that which is
that eddie has been in the industry
forever
he started out as
eddie murphy's
bodyguard that's how he started out and
eventually he got into the industry as a
as a you know a stunt guy and he
eventually got into the place where he
now coordinates all the stunts and
he has just a long history in the film
and he has a lot of experience so
he gave me many life lessons along the
way
but in this one
he
he'd done it so much where he didn't
even need to read the paper it didn't
matter because this is the guy who wrote
it and he knows if it's good or not
that was his only point i would know if
it's good or not and if it's not
appropriate for the film we're not going
to do it
so that's that's how that decision got
made
you